[Musik]
einen großer applaus bitte für das
luftwaffen chor der deutschen bundeswehr
aus erfurt herr major gut herr major
herzlich willkommen wie meine damen und
herren das ist major wunderle schön dass
wir bei uns in wien sind ist das der
erste offizier ball den sie persönlich
besuchen
persönlich für mich ist es der zweite
ich durfte vor zwei jahren gastdirigent
seien beim ball orchester aber jetzt in
dieser funktion als leiter eines
musikers und auch für das
luftwaffenmusikkorps erfurt ist es
wirklich premiere
was könnte es schöneres geben meine
damen und herren als zwei armeen die
österreichische und die deutsche die
gemeinsam musizieren
wir werden heute noch sehr viele von
ihnen hören dankeschön applaus für die
österreichisch-deutsche musik heute
abend gering ladies and gentlemen wort
kamen zu die anleihen die fotos auf die
austrian abend vor sich herzlich
willkommen sehr geehrte damen und herren
zum 94
ball der offiziere hier in der wiener
hofburg
die wiener hofburg das wissen sie ist
das stammhaus der habsburger hier in
wien jahrhundertelang der große palast
in dem hier vieles stattgefunden hat wie
auch heute
wir sind sehr stolz und froh dass der
oberbefehlshaber österreich der
österreichische armee herr
bundespräsident alexander van der bellen
auch heute wieder den ehrenschutz
übernommen hat julian hat der präsident
professor alexander van der bellen ist
in wörth rematch oft ist wohl zu 1 mw
ebenso great for defense hier
wir freuen uns natürlich sehr dass
unsere neue ministerin heute abend hieß
die wir dann später auch noch vorstellen
werden und natürlich auch dass der chef
des generalstabes hier ist
golden silver ist timo boll zu knight
ladies and gentlemen watchers
transformatoren silva wird auch keine
baut austrian cultural history of music
zone la parra dass die inspiration des
heutigen abends kommt dass der bulderner
operetten ehre und deshalb heißt heute
alles jeweils gold und silber was wird
passieren es wird ganz einfach sein
einzug der jungen damen und herren ein
komitee bestehend aus 120 damen und
herren und davon wie sehr dass wir sehr
viele waren gäste aus bosnien
herzegowina und deutschland bei uns
haben werden und danach zieht in einem
feierlichen einzug der militär block 1
der zivil blog attachés und der minister
blog aber meine damen und herren mit der
gemeinsam gespielten eröffnungsfanfare
wird dieser ball jetzt zumindest für den
künstlerischen teil eröffnet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unter den klängen der wille der
polonaise schokokuss 40 ziehen wie
gesagt jetzt unsere jungen damen und
herren des großen komitee sein und was
beachtenswert auch da sein wird ist die
zusammenarbeit der nationen natürlich
sehr viele österreichische ware aber
auch kolleginnen und kollegen ganz
bosnien herzegowina und deutschland um
so die verbundenheit des
österreichischen heeres mit den armeen
europas zu zeigen hier
der öffentliche und der hoffentlich sehr
schöne einzug unserer jungdamen
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das sind sie
unsere 120 paare bitte einen großen
applaus für die vertreterinnen des
herzens bosnien herzegowina deutschland
und österreich und hier ist der
feierliche einzug unserer ehrengäste der
militär blog zivil blog unsere attachés
und der minister blog herzlich
willkommen unsere ehrengäste
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im hafen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren bitte erheben sie
sich für die österreichische bundeshymne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
o
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bitte nehmen sie wieder platz er ist
vorhin schon gesagt dieses komitee ist
heute ganz speziell weil wir freunde
haben hier aus bosnien herzegowina aus
deutschland und natürlich viele viele
aus österreich dürftig sie beide mit mir
mit bitten meine damen und herren bitte
applaus für ein ein eines unserer fahrer
aus deutschland bitte kommen sie mit
dann freut mich ganz besonders auf ein
bar aus bosnien herzegowina bitte kommen
sie mit applaus für uns sehr freuen das
herz aus bosnien herzegowina und last
but not least aus österreich applaus für
uns seit drei paare der die freundschaft
zwischen diesen ländern zeigen guten amt
da bis sie fangen sie heißen an welchen
rang haben sie welche haben sie fähnrich
ist mir stolz dass österreich jetzt auch
endlich haben eine frauen der spitze des
heeres
sie sagt wie ist ihr name andreas unser
wurzacher was haben sie fern man sich
etwas
das ist eine angenehme aufgabe
miteinander hier aufzutreten
[Applaus]
sie sind aus österreich woher genau ein
bisschen außerhalb von wien
sie haben zumindest ist die um gefahren
von prozent herzegowina
woher kommen sie und zwei freunde aus
deutschland beziehen sich als
deutschland aus österreich aus
deutschland woher kommen sie aus berlin
wunderschön zum ersten mal in der
hofburg glück nicht darf ich jemanden
anbieten wolfgang oder woher kommen sie
auch aus berlin
auch aus berlin zum ersten mal hier in
der hofburg zum zweiten mal mit ihrer
bei den bayern ja wohl das hat so gut
gefallen dass sie wiedergekommen sind
auf jeden fall dass die deutschen ja
schon gehabt haben über einen
jahrzehnten nämlich zuerst verfahren der
leyen und dann annegret kramp
karrenbauer
ich habe lange gibt für diesen namen
haben wir jetzt auch in form unserer
wunderbaren die japaner war auch ein
zeichen in ihrem land das sie erinnern
sie sich noch daran die zum ersten mal
eine frau bundesministerin für
verteidigung bei ihnen wurde ja wohl
daran erinnern wir uns
und was haben sie sich damals ganz
ehrlich gedacht um gottes willen oder
das geht gut 9 unbeschriebenes blatt
unbeschriebenes klappt das ist klar der
tanzstunde erlebnis kamen er behalten
dankeschön einen riesenapplaus völker
verbinden
bosnien herzegowina deutschland und
österreich wir meine damen und herren
das kann ich ihnen sagen sind hier am
sichersten ort österreichs heute denn
wir sind ja nicht nur geschützt durch
die truppen des österreichischen
bundesheeres sondern auch um seinen
innenminister haben also so sicher wie
das haben wir sichern immer das ist ganz
klar
und jetzt kommt ein star der schon zum
vierten mal hier ist darum ist sie
wieder da weil sie immer so beliebt ist
beim publikum und weil sie genau das
repräsentiert was österreichische
künstler haben und
was sie alles kann hier kommt die koralm
und meine lippen sie küssen so heiß
[Musik]
ich weiß es selber nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
beide
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
pauli
[Musik]
un binnen
minute
mal
[Musik]
vor
ich hab mir
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie wahr
eine gewinn
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nicht gegeben
meine damen und herren kammersängerin in
lissabon
[Applaus]
musikant forsys artikel musiker tattoo
wir bringen jetzt schätze
österreichische militär kapellmeister in
diesem tattoo sehen sie und hören sind
in erzherzog albrecht marsch dem
doppeladler deutschmeister dann
zigeunerweisen mit einem großartigen
solisten nämlich pornobilder uns dann
den radetzky-marsch wieder zum auszug
bitte begrüßen sie mit großem applaus
die gardemusik hier aus österreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die
sie sind das land kal infanterieregiment
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren an der geige
david villa zigeunerweisen amerika
koalition wird meine damen und herren
geht es weiter unter der musikalischen
leitung hier auf dem parkett die bretter
die die welt bedeuten mit unserem
stadtführer vizeleutnant springer hier
ist er die geheime bundes in österreichs
bitte klatschen sie mit die gardemusik
mit dem auszug aus dem radetzkymarsch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das war der rat es gehört meine damen
und herren und die gardemusik des
österreichischen bundesheeres jetzt ist
es soweit jetzt kommen die jungen damen
und herren dran
ja telefonieren und telefon ist etwas
ganz ganz wichtiges aber ich nehme an
dass die herrschaften hier sich nicht
oder greifen einige herren auf dem handy
nein so war das wirklich nicht gemeint
79 telefonieren jetzt herrn sie wollen
sie wirklich die polizei informieren
bietet das sitzt die oberbefehlshaber
der österreichische armee und schuhe in
die familie schließlich der
oberbefehlshaber entschuldige und die
rolle der polizei anrufen sagt sie das
ist mir jetzt wahnsinnig peinlich meine
damen und herren ich habe nicht geglaubt
dass das passiert aber ich habe auch
nicht gewusst und habs jetzt erfahren
dass er seine sensationelle polka gibt
meine damen und herren von keinem
geringeren als von johann strauß mit dem
titel durchs telefon und durst telefon
ist jetzt die eröffnung
[Musik]
das war unser folge durchs telefon
jetzt gibt es ein paar blumen für die
damen
[Musik]
danke schön und jung da man herrn
komitee die blümchen
meine damen und herren ich glaube jetzt
ist es an der zeit um die offizielle
begrüßung durch den chef des
generalstabes general robert bringen
bitte herr general
vorher gibt es noch blumen für die
fabrik- und für die frau bundesminister
und jetzt meine damen und herren der
rolle des chief general robert brigger
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerin sehr
geschätzte besucher des offiziers paar
2020 es ist für mich sowohl als chef des
generalstabes als auch in meiner
funktion als präsident des vereins alt
neustadt eine besondere freude und
auszeichnung sie zum ball der offiziere
2020 begrüßen zu dürfen so wird unser
ball jedes jahr durch die anwesenheit
höchstrangiger gäste ausgezeichnet und
die versuche im verständnis dass ich in
anbetracht der vielzahl der er und
festgäste nur einige persönlichkeiten
stellvertretend für alle gäste begrüßen
werde die anwesenheit der politischen
leitung unseres ministeriums zeichnet
diese bei veranstaltungen besonders aus
und so begrüße ich respektvoll frau
bundesministerin für landesverteidigung
magister klaudia tanner mit ihrem gatten
martin frau bundesministerin herzlich
willkommen
in langjähriger und bewährter
verbundenheit bei der zusammenarbeit zur
erfüllung von einsatzaufgaben ist es mir
eine freude den herrn bundesminister für
inneres karl hammer mit seiner gattin
katharina herzlich begrüßen zu dürfen
der bundesminister es freut mich dass
sie da sind es ist meine ehre haben
volksanwalt peter arme und erstmalig am
balkan offiziere begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]
weiters freut es mich besonders dass
unsere ehemaligen bundesminister dr
werner fasslabend und generalmajor
magister thomas stahl immer unter uns
sehen und uns die ehre geben herzlich
willkommen
ich begrüße den obmann des
landesverteidigungsausschusses herren
abgeordneten zum nationalrat reagiert dr
reinhard bösch mit den wer sprechern der
im nationalrat vertretenen parteien
er bringt ihm ein aufrichtiges
willkommen am ball der offiziere
ich darf den generalsekretär im
verteidigungsministerium magistertitel
kandlhofer herzlich begrüßen
dieter schön dass du unser gast bist
für alle dienststellenleiter des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung und kommandanten des
österreichischen bundesheeres begrüße
ich stellvertretend wenn leiter der
sektion bereitstellung general leuten
und magister norbert g hat als partner
des österreichischen bundesheeres haben
wir die deutsche bundeswehr eingeladen
sie ist mir her es ist mir daher eine
besondere ehre an der spitze den
generalinspekteur der bundeswehr general
eberhard zorn mit seiner gattin petra
begrüßen zu dürfen
über hat freut mich dass die bahn ist in
bestform
ladies and gentlemen wellkamp vienna
repräsentiert vor sie sind international
flavors oder bridge fast dual view wie
bass es aber gestern erwischte
präsentieren in german company reva wars
und entscheidet standing at.mosphere der
hofburg alles es soll entwicklern
especially the pit.de assistant
secretary of defense android winternitz
von der united states rempel vorkamen
ebenso die herren generalleutnant der
jörg vollmer und jürgen knappe aus
deutschland und herren korpskommandanten
aldo schellenberg aus der schweiz
herzlich willkommen welcome tour 2000
trennte offices voll eingeleitet der die
j allocation sun aus rio präsentiert
ganz besonders möchte ich die große zahl
unserer gäste der deutschen bundeswehr
begrüßen stellvertretend die studenten
der beiden bundeswehr-universitäten im
eröffnungs komitee und die angehörigen
des luftwaffenmusikkorps aus erfurt das
uns musikalisch durch den heutigen abend
begleiten wird
ich begrüße alle angehörigen der
absolventen vereinigung alt neustadt an
der spitze den ehemaligen chef des
generalstabes und präsidenten general in
ruhe magister edmund entacher
ich begrüße unsere militär akademiker
mit ihren bezaubernden tanzpartnerinnen
in den reihen des eröffnungs komitees
die erstmals das parkett des balls der
offiziere betreten
nehmen sie nun anstatt des telefons ihre
damen bei der hand und erobern sie
gemeinsam den ball der offiziere ein
herzliches willkommen in allen
geschätzte ehrengäste liebe ball
besucher aus nah und fern wir haben denn
beide offiziere 2020 unter das motto
gold und silber gestellt diese beiden
edelmetalle sind zeichen für wert und
beständigkeit sie bezaubern und
verleihen als schmuck oder rangabzeichen
glanz und würde
beständigkeit und glanz das gilt auch
für den 73 beide offiziere gleichgültig
ob in uniform oder zivil ob nationale
oder internationale gäste ob jugend
wobei jung gebliebene alle teilen ihre
freude an dieser rauschenden weihnacht
in der wunderbaren hofburg
ich denke werte gäste sie stimmen mir zu
dass all jene personen die mit viel
engagement und hohen
organisationsaufwand zum gelingen dieses
herausragenden beigetragen haben ein
aufrichtiges dankeschön und einen
besonderen applaus verdienen
ich wünsche uns allen gute unterhaltung
eine wunderbare und beschwingte bei
nacht mit unvergesslichen eindrücken und
darf nun sie sehr geschätzte frau
bundesministerin um die eröffnung des
balles aussuchen
herzlichen dank ladies and gentlemen der
förderung ist auf national defense
klaudia tanner
sehr geehrter herr chef des generalstabs
präsident der vereinigung als neustadt
sehr geehrte ehren und festgäste
soldatinnen und soldaten
sehr geehrte damen und herren in ihrem
programm heft stammt noch das der herr
bundesminister diesen wunderbaren bei
heute eröffnen wird
eine umso größere freude und besondere
ehre ist es mir heute hier vor ihnen zu
stehen als erster
verteidigungsministerin der republik
österreich
dieser bei ist nicht nur ein beide
offiziere bei des österreichischen
bundesheeres er ist vielmehr ein ganz
besonderer bei der internationale
beachtung gefunden hat so wie unser
generalstabschef das schon zum ausdruck
gebracht hat ich glaube wir wollen heute
ein ganz großes dankeschön sagen vor
allem aber denjenigen dem jungen damen
und herren komitee die die
internationalität ganz besonders
widerspiegeln mit unseren
österreicherinnen und österreichern mit
den kolleginnen und kollegen aus
deutschland und aus bosnien und
herzegowina
das war eine wunderbare einlage vielen
vielen dank
danke daher generalstabschef bei
denjenigen schon gedankt die hinter den
kulissen mit jacken jahr
das bundesheer hat gezeigt dass es
organisieren kann
das ist hilfreich bei festen wie diesen
und lebt es notwendig bei einsätzen
heute aber wollen wir alle feiern
ich wünsche ihnen ein uns eine
unvergessliche haus schöne weihnacht und
dafür mit den 73 beide offiziere 2020
eröffnen
dankeschön meine damen und herren
bundesministerin japan amt war
bundesminister das ist schon ein
erhebendes gefühl die letzte frau die
diese etwas zu sagen hatte wirkte maria
theresia und jetzt werde ich wirklich
der böse überraschung
63 prozent der österreicherinnen und
österreicher stehen auf dieses
bundesheer das ist doch eine
zweidrittelmehrheit und das bedeutet
schon sehr viel
das bedeutet sehr viel und es zeigt vor
allem dass das österreichische
bundesheer unsere sicherheitsgarantie es
und das ist unser aller gemeinsame
aufgabe ist es wieder zu einem voll
einsatzfähigen bundesheer zu machen das
würde ich mir wünschen von uns einfach
war bundesminister sie sind ja bekannt
dafür dass sie schwierige funktionen
übernehmen
beim letzten job haben sie auch herrn in
ein heim gefahren gehört nämlich in jagd
uniformen und jäger wandeln wo geben sie
lieber befehle bei den schmucken heeres
uniformen oder in die der
österreichische land eine sehr gute
frage
spass beiseite es gibt wohl keine
großartigen expertinnen und experten als
im österreichischen bundesheer und im
verteidigungsministerium
ich habe das schon mehrfach gesagt ich
würde denjenigen ihnen ein gerne das
vertrauen schenken und hoffe und bin
überzeugt davon dass sich diese
loyalität auch von ihnen ein erfahren
jetzt aber glaube ich jetzt vor allem
darum zu feiern
ja das ist das erste mal dass ein
verteidigungsminister österreich seinen
hand bekommt möge das fest rauschen
beginn an das geschehen und sie haben
die anderen ministerien
wir haben eine damen und herren jetzt
ist es soweit jetzt kommt der
eröffnungswalzer des jungen damen und
herren kommt ist gemeinsam mit der walze
formation elmayer mit einem der
wunderschönen und bekannten weil sie
diese kennen nämlich gold und silber bis
hin zu den magischen worten dieses
balles nein nicht alles panzer sondern
dass wir die jungen bei anderen später
sein möge dabei beginnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren bevor die
magischen worte fallen herzlichen
willkommen hier beim ball der offiziere
live auf unserem live stream des
österreichischen bundesheeres am unseren
youtube kanal ist das was die fischl
opening auf der neuen dvd offices and we
look forward to meet you get ermittlern
zeremonie alles
[Applaus]
[Musik]